this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everyone I'm Ruth I'm a third year
PhD student in plant breeding and
genetics and today I'll be talking about
my thesis work focused on understanding
the fine skill recombination landscape
in Maize
so let's start with what is meiotic
recombination meiotic recombination
takes place during meiosis one and at a
high level is essentially just shuffling
of genetic segments between chromosomes
so as you can see in the schematic you
have two homologous chromosomes they're
paired they're undergoing in exchange
you zoom in on this area and this is
called the double holiday Junction it's
the actual site of the exchange and then
eventually the double holiday Junction
be resolved into a crossover event and
you can see in the homologous
chromosomes they swapped a segment but
recombination is specifically important
for plant breeding because it creates
novel allelic combinations and I'll go
through a really common situation in
which recombination is helpful for plant
breeding so oftentimes you have two
lines one is high yielding but
disusceptible and the other is maybe low
yielding but has some disease resistance
so we're trying to introgress that
disease resistance into the high
yielding Elite background and from that
cross we often want progeny that are
high yielding with disease resistance
however we oftentimes end up with these
like medium yielding but they're disease
resistant and this is due to a
phenomenon called linkage drug so those
unwanted yield loci are in close
proximity to the disease-resistant loci
causing this only the progenes only have
medium yielding and the problem of
linkage drag can really be demonstrated
in the Maze crossover landscape so this
is chromosome one
um and as you can see it has a very
biased distribution most crossovers are
taking place towards chromosome ends
towards telomeres and there's a really
large suppression region at the
centromere in the region around the
century are called the pericentromere
region so recently we delve in to see
how this landscape correlated with Gene
density and it correlates pretty well
with Gene density however about 20
percent of all Maize genes are in the
pericentromeric region which means
they're consistently not undergoing
recombination
so as I mentioned
um that title it says we just don't know
anything about
fine skill recombination landscape
um but I'm interested in understanding
at a really fine resolution what's
happening with recombination and the
purpose of this is to help inform
breeding processes Downstream
um so if we know what's happening on a
really fine scale that can be used to
improve things that rely upon
recombination like ETL mapping but also
General breeding programs however the
data the crossover data we have right
now only allows us to do presence
abscess predictions of Crossovers and to
actually estimate recombination rate we
need a really large amount of crossovers
but to do that obviously we need really
large experimental populations that's
not always feasible so to sidestep this
I used historical data to get a really
large crossover data set
and the way I went about getting this
data set is to use identity by descent
analysis also called the IBD analysis so
IBD analysis essentially just identifies
haplotype blocks or unrecombined regions
between samples as you can see
um the schematic it is two individuals
and they share an IBD segment because
they have shared ancestry
and over many generations over lots of
recombinations
um you get smaller and smaller segments
but eventually
um we can still see them at the
boundaries of them we can infer them to
be past recombination break points so
Ides in IBD analysis on 26 diverse Maize
inbreds with their new de novo
assemblies very high quality
and found about a hundred thousand
crossovers for just chromosome one
so this is already fantastic we have a
really large data set so I went ahead
and I did this for all 10 chromosomes of
that maze has and from all of these you
can see the very classic u-shaped
distribution that
um maze recombination Landscapes
um look like and you can see also um as
a proof of concept chromosome 6
centromere is way to the left as you can
see that U is also way to the left so
before this IBD analysis
um we could only have prediction models
that was binary classification and again
it was difficult to assign recombination
rate with not a lot of crossovers so
after this analysis we can really
explore recombination rate at a really
fine scale and then also and understand
what influences recombination rate at a
fine scale
so to do this I constructed okay the
title says using ipdns to construct a
machine learning model to predict the
combination rate
um and I had about 18 features that 10
KB resolution and I kind of been the the
features into different
um
I don't know classes so the first of
which is histone related so these are
histones in their Associated methylation
or acetylation and then DNA methylation
related and
um obviously plants have three types of
methylation but I just want to point out
we included Lois CG interval if you look
at metal plots of crossovers at the
midpoint of these crossovers there's
this huge dip in CG methylation also CHD
methylation and we and because we're
averaging methylation over the whole 10
KB region we wanted to understand how
low can methylation actually go at the
midpoint of crossovers and then the next
feature was more chromosome position
related so this has to do more with
chromosome Dynamics and mechanisms so
distance centimeter distance to the
nearest telomere and then finally DNA
sequence related which is just Gene
Snips and indels
so the model actually does quite well so
the r squared is 0.836 and this is
signaling about 83 percent of the
variance of our data could be explained
by the model
and the root mean squared error is just
the error between the predicted and
actual values and we want this as low as
possible but I'll go through the first
uh the top five also this is a feature
ranking plot and it's telling us
um the most predictable features from
the model
um so the first of which is distance to
centromere and this is really
interesting to us because when
chromosomes first pair we think they
Pair by the telomeres so in
recombination starts you're going from
telomeres into the centromere and of
course with crossover interference if
you have a crossovers forming near
chromosome ends you cannot get them
formed during closer to the sanctuary so
this signaling to us that chromosome
Dynamics might be at play is really
interesting
um and the same goes for distance to
nearest telomere but then we also have
some things that like CG CH and ecosm
occupancy which are all signaling to us
some features about open chromatin have
to do with predicting recombination so I
wanted to see what the most the least
amount of features we can have and still
get good prediction
so actually you only need five features
to explain the same amount of variance
so actually the r squared went up a
little bit to
0.8642 and this is the um the model the
best model I am saying so distance to
centromere chcchg methylation and
distance nearest telomere and you
consume occupancy are all you need
really to predict recombination rate
um and to compare this to the binary
model and that is just the presence
absence model you can see there's
different feature rankings
um so this is if um this is a plot from
the binary prediction model you can see
the the feature that explains the most
variance is Snip density however
um that's not even in the top five for
our recombination rate model
um so we think that recombination rate
in particular rather than just binary
prediction of crossovers uh may be
influenced by chromosome Dynamics with
distances to centromere and telomere
um being one of the biggest features
so in summary I utilize historical data
to obtain a really large amount of
Crossovers and then use that large data
set to predict recombination rate and a
10 KB resolution I just want to stress
we have never been able to predict
recombination rate so the fact that we
not only have great data but also are
able to do it is already fantastic and I
just like to thank my lab for supporting
me and my mentors and also NSF on RT for
my funding sources thank you
and I can take any questions
yeah so the question is what are
chromosome Dynamics so it's a broad term
but basically I'm talking about
mechanistically what's happening with
chromosomes during actual meiosis so a
lot of it are just hypotheses that we
have about how chromosomes pair at what
point they make double strand breaks
um so this model is kind of like a side
step to actually doing a lot of wet lab
things to look at how chromosomes are
actually interacting with each other and
how they're undergoing recombination
so I'd say it's like an umbrella term
for just like mechanistically what are
chromosomes doing
yes so our distance to centromere and
from centromere and distance from
telomero is really independent
measurements if they were Point
estimates they wouldn't be would they
but there's probably slop in the
measurement is that with the issues yeah
So eventually okay so the question was
what's the difference between distance
to central air and distance scenarios
telomere
they should be telling us the same
things
um we agree we hope to one day combine
them into like maybe a ratio of distance
to the telomere just centromere but I
also think the um so this model was
trained on all 10 chromosomes so each of
them obviously have different
orientations of where the centromere is
and
um I don't know other chromatin
differences between the chromosomes
um
so I think it has to do with there's two
telomeres and the distances to each
centromere is not always the same we've
tried to scale it but that hasn't really
made a difference in the model
yeah we'd eventually like to combine
them so it's just one term
ination
it's a big block it's not just for
another particularly
yeah okay so the question was what's
going on with Amazon one
I'll show you this figure so you have
this like suppression and then it goes
up again and it goes down again a little
bit so what we think is actually this is
at the point in which crossover
interference like stops working so like
if you have crossovers forming over here
then they go okay like we're far away
enough we can form crossovers here and
then the suppression of the centromere
and from the analysis we did you can
kind of see a lot of chromosomes behave
like that so you kind of have this like
bump at some point because a lot of
chromosomes have a long arm and then
they have a short arm so we think it has
to do with crossover interference
okay thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu